okay as always recordings of our virtual
meetups will be available on youtube
about a week after the meetup and we'll
post a message on our meetup page when
the recording is ready
next i am very pleased to introduce our
speaker today
victor wu
victor wu is the ceo and co-founder of
ensembl ensemble helps companies make
decisions faster by improving their
communications cultures in the remote
work and hybrid work pandemic age
previously victor was head of product at
tilt a kubernetes dev tools company he
previously also worked at get lab and
grubhub
today our questions be handled um
just in the middle of the talk so if you
have a question feel free to meet
yourself or put them in the chat and
i'll ask them to victor
take it away victor great um yes so
we don't have a lot of people here so um
is that one person as huge or do you
want to
introduce yourself might as well since
we have a you know a lot of people here
oh and they left
so i'm happy to uh just uh go through uh
the ideas especially if this is recorded
um is that is that a good idea
yeah we do get um views on our youtube
page as well
okay so yeah i wanted to make this make
make sure this is useful for everybody
so if um if this is just recording
that's that's also
great so for people who are now watching
on youtube
um yeah so i'm going to give a little
bit of background on remote work um
we're all doing remote work right now
chances are if you're watching this
video um you might be watching it
again after it was posted
on the channel you got a notification so
you might actually be watching it during
the day um you might be watching it on
your phone um so
um it's a whole new world where a lot of
information or consumption is is being
done asynchronously and so that's going
to be a big topic today um in what i
want to to chat about and in particular
i wanted to um talk about how we work
day to day so
unfortunately um
during this pandemic i think a lot of
people have been
um you know just inundated with a lot of
zoom meetings and
perhaps that's why you didn't want to
join this money just watching it on
youtube um because it is so laborious
and you're going to the office um so if
you're watching this video probably uh
you're in the pi data community you're
probably some type of technical person
or you work with technical folks on your
day-to-day job you're coming to work um
but despite you know maybe before
pandemic you were doing a lot of uh you
know work by yourself or with your team
in the office but now you're spending a
lot of the days uh on zoom in
or maybe you're starting to get back
into the office but regardless um
in my experience and working with a lot
of companies um a lot of folks are just
spending a lot of time in meetings um
and if you're in a technical role um and
you're in a smaller company that might
not be the case so congratulations that
that's great for you if you're in a
larger company you you probably are in
more meetings but if you're in a larger
company
but you're in say a smaller team or
there's a business
sponsor
or or somebody on your team that is
handling a lot of those meetings and you
just get you know a list of tasks to do
that that's also great um but today i
wanted to focus on what knowledge
workers do and so when i say knowledge
workers i don't mean just tech workers
like yourself i mean essentially
everybody that
fortunately during this pandemic can
continue to do work so as we know during
this pending a lot of people couldn't
continue to do work maybe they're in the
restaurant industry maybe they're in
retail for for whatever reason but if
you're a knowledge worker pretty much
the definition of is if you were able to
continue to work uh then you're a
knowledge worker so that's anybody that
can get their work done in front of a
computer most of the time and so if you
look at the numbers uh tech workers are
actually a very small proportion of
those folks knowledge workers um there's
many many knowledge workers in the world
but only small percentage of them are
actually doing what we call uh tech work
or it or whatever term you want to um
apply to that and so what i'm going to
talk about today really has broad
implications on um on just
the
the working staff or or the working
folks
in this world frankly going forward
especially in this world of of covid and
and
of work from home and hybrid work and
you know for me for example i thought
that we would be done
this covet silliness by now but it's
it's clear to me now that that we're
going to be here for
for a couple of years at a minimum and
things are going to change so i think
this will be really relevant for for you
watching it today
whether you're in tech you're working in
tech whether you're you know you want to
do a career in middle management where
you want to do a different type of
career
chances are you're going to be doing
some type of knowledge work so that
that's what i wanted to set
put give a setting there additionally i
wanted to
give a little bit of background on where
this remote work or what what folks are
doing
nowadays and what i think they will be
doing going forward in terms of remote
work um so
for for some during this past year that
might have been mean that you know in
march or april especially if you're in
north america you you ended up on zoom
um you know since march
and then maybe for a month or two you
you were on zoom all day and then soon
your company said that this is
ridiculous we can't be on zoom all day
and then you you start to do different
things maybe you use more slack
maybe um you reduce the zoom usage maybe
you try different tools
for example some companies tried vr for
example which is pretty crazy there's
one company i knew that uh send oculus
sent oculus headsets to all their
employees across the world um in like
the middle of summer and then they were
trying to do that
and some folks
uh there's some other tools out there
where um for better or worse it's
not just only zoom but you're literally
online all day um and then so some of
these tools are you're having you might
have an avatar and you're walking around
in your screen and try to mimic the
office setting so so on and so forth so
so maybe you're you're one of those
companies um and you've experienced that
and so so yeah so i'm sure there's a
diversity of folks who have been really
experiencing different things throughout
this pandemic and i wanted to just
acknowledge that because it has
been a tough year and i also want to
acknowledge folks that um
well i mean there's there's lots of
folks that that just maybe just lost
their job because of downsizing i i i
was at a company and we worked with
customers i can't necessarily name that
customer
but that customer was a tech company but
they had a strong operation side of the
business so when um the operation side
of the business didn't need
that many um because of covet they
couldn't do that much business
that had a ripple effect on the tech
uh ecosystem
within that company a lot of people got
laid off so if you're one of those folks
i want to acknowledge you as well so
there's been a lot of changes and on the
flip side there's been a lot of
opportunities a lot of tech workers now
can do remote work um
they you know you've hear stories of
people moving to different cities so so
there's been a lot of great things there
and then one one group of people i did
want to acknowledge last uh and
certainly not least is people just with
families at home and have been
struggling um i worked with uh during
the pandemic i i uh i had some co-worker
or the company that i worked uh with was
largely based in new york uh if you
remember at the beginning of the
pandemic in the united states uh new
york was was hit really pretty heavily
and what's worse is that in new york a
lot of folks are just in small
apartments and so imagine you're in a
small apartment your spouse is working
your significant other is working your
kid cannot go to school and it's just a
terrible situation so i want to
acknowledge you uh if you were in that
situation or still in that situation i
had a co-worker who literally
they were working in
in the middle of the night and that's
the only time they could work and during
the day they would have to just take
care of their of their kids um so so
it's it's been a tough year and and
things hopefully for you if you're
watching this video you've gone to some
steady state maybe like as mentioned if
you have kids you've gotten you figure
out child care
maybe you found that job maybe you are
have a plan with your spouse and so on
and so forth um but yeah it's a whole
new world and i wanted to
acknowledge that that situation now but
i also wanted to sort of tease and like
scratch that itch if you might have one
from an intellectual perspective what is
this remote work why why are we stuck in
zoo meetings all day
so there were studies even before the
meeting if you if you just google this
you know google
uh you know people enjoying meetings or
well you can just google meetings and
people thinking whether meetings are
good or not you'll see a bunch of
results there's you know a good number
of research papers harvard business
review uh gartner those types of
publications and consulting firms what
they'll tell you is that people have
always hated meetings
meetings never made sense at all
and so you would hear statistics of up
to 60 70
of folks that just said meetings are
useless they're ineffective why are we
in meetings all day and so
um one takeaway and you know i'll try to
you know sum up some of the takeaways
from today one of the takeaways from
today is that
the the
pandemic is not something
that
necessarily caused a lot of the
the the the pain that you're feeling
within the workplace of course it caused
a lot of the pains that i mentioned
earlier within your your work situation
but um think of before you were in the
pandemic think of all the times where
you went to that meeting that you
thought was really silly and didn't make
sense think of the other times where
you're really frustrated where you try
to deliver work to your manager or a
co-worker and they didn't read your
email they didn't read your work and
think about all those efficiencies there
or inefficiencies there well kovid was
just
shining a light on this on this trend
and so that's a big takeaway here is
that
enterprise workplace or the enterprise
work for knowledge workers
has increasingly
suffered from this trend of things just
becoming increasingly
inefficient and you know
what does inefficiency mean well if
you're
if you're ceo of a big company and you
have thousands of workers that that's
going to affect your bottom line uh if
you're a uh an individual contributor in
ic and you got into your field you're a
data scientist you're a data engineer
you're a product manager and you wanted
to go to this company to make a change
um but you spend six hours of your day
in meetings or just stand-up meetings
status update meetings and you thought
you wanted to change the world but you
go to work every day and you're in
six-hour meetings and you're drained and
you you have two hours of
free time spread
in 15-minute chunks you're not even
doing any work anymore and you're
feeling the pain of that and you thought
you could
um
you know really change the world and you
can't well
that that's horrible and and i feel
sorry for you and but that shouldn't be
the case and so
covet has shined the light on these
things um and i'm glad to say that many
companies
especially smaller companies have
recognized this and taken this advantage
of of the coveted world to realign their
business a lot of businesses are
starting up i started a business right
in the middle of the pandemic earlier
this year um and and we're just
specifically addressing this problem but
many companies uh in this world are able
to start from scratch but many larger
companies are not um and so so we're
gonna see this shift over time
but suffice it to say
um again the takeaway is that kovit is
not introducing problems it's just
making problems that were always there
really obvious to people and that has
all these knock-on effects one of them
is that um you know if you're doing
remote work and you're gonna get a job
at a new awesome startup then you don't
have to put up with all this politics
and six hours of meetings every day um
and that's great um and so so so we're
seeing some of that right now um but at
the same time
i wanted to again emphasize that uh
tovid is not is not um is not
introducing problems it is shining light
on existing problems on these existing
trends um and if you want to look at the
history so i'm now gonna you know talk a
little bit about the history is um you
know there's all these confluence of
trends one of the trends is i mentioned
knowledge work right so if you think
about yeah i'm not going to go all the
way back
really back in history you can think of
what is the history of work and you can
like think of like egyptians building
the pyramids that that's work right but
you know fast forward a lot to think
about um you know factories right like
posts uh you know industrial revolution
you had factories um and then you had
factories and what that meant is
because of the industrial revolution
people went to work had um
had had a concept of going to work
before the industrial revolution you
didn't really have that concept maybe
you were doing an apprenticeship maybe
you were on a farm so work is not really
work it's sort of work as blended with
your life which is really funny because
a lot of people now nowadays talk about
work life balance back then it was it
was already work like that as well it
was not much balance but there was
definitely no separation of work and
life it was because of the industrial
revolution people are in factories now
there was this concept of like a nine to
five or i'm sure it was longer hours
than that but then there was a
separation between work and life post
world war ii you had a lot of uh
industry and and construction and things
like that and then you had this rise of
knowledge work and so
the reason why we have nine to five in
knowledge work again if you think about
that we don't why do we need a nine to
five especially if we're doing a lot of
the things that i'm going to talk about
today you actually don't need a nine to
five and in fact a lot of again these
new york companies are not doing the
nine to five the nine to five is
actually a legacy of factory work
because of hours if you're working in
you know the modern day amazon factory
you're working these shifts or if you're
you're a doctor or if you're a retailer
or you're in doing these industries
where you have to have this real-time
nature
then then there's this this concept of
shift but knowledge work doesn't need
shifts at the end of the day but because
work evolved from from shift work
that's why knowledge work is in shifts
so that that's another thing to take
away from from a historical perspective
uh where where knowledge work is only
going to be more and more dominant in
this world is going to be led by a
digital revolution right you know
because uh you know uh you know you've
heard things like mark andreessen the
vcc software is eating the world so
so so this is pi data chicago marc
andreessen uh one of the early people
that made mozilla firefox uh and
graduated from urbana-champaign a couple
hours south of chicago so he said like
software is eating the world so there's
this trend of digitization software
that's knowledge work and so all
companies are becoming software
companies so
not that everybody's going to become a
programmer but
there is more and more programming and
software jobs and then there's more
knowledge work surrounding those jobs so
consequently
more jobs are going to become knowledge
jobs and then there's also other trends
obviously automation and so in this
community you all know about ml and ai
and all those things in automation so
that's another reason why a lot more
jobs are going to become well there's
going to be less automated jobs so that
so the proportion at least and and if
you know some people say like oh all
these jobs are going away so hopefully a
lot of these jobs will be placed by
knowledge working knowledge worker jobs
so we see a big trend toward knowledge
work and and then so so then it really
comes down to why does knowledge work
need to be even and shift does that even
make sense so so that actually does not
make sense
and so
now the the question is then what is the
right model for knowledge work if
we see this problem with too many
meetings so too much essentially too
much synchronicity we see the problem of
um
uh
shift work
which you know knowledge work doesn't
really need shift work you don't really
if if most of your day is you know
writing a code as a programmer running a
model as a data scientist or if you're a
manager even you're doing a lot of
organization you're meeting with folks
so if you can reduce
those meeting times then essentially you
don't actually really need a lot of this
synchronicity you can actually get a lot
done asynchronously so how can you do
that well there's actually a great model
for this um that's something that a lot
of folks don't realize that we've
actually been doing a lot of
asynchronous work and so if you're
watching this video you'll probably have
some technical background you're
probably already doing a lot of this
work that you don't even know
and so the example
is um
i don't think
we're going to be able to i don't think
on the youtube here you're going to be
able to see
um
i was going to paste some things in a
chat box what i'll do is actually just
share my screen really quickly here
and so i'll give you a glance at some of
the tools or history
really quickly here on on my uh
on my
on my notepad here or what is this adam
um and so i wanted to highlight so these
are a bunch of links on wikipedia links
but you know you can ignore all the urls
here but i wanted to highlight a lot of
these open source tools so so there's a
lot of links here different companies
and tools i wanted to highlight a couple
things
one of them is
again
we don't have to go to the beginning of
like history and computing you know we
don't have to go to touring or anything
like that we can just jump all the way
to the 60s and 70s where
computing was starting to become popular
and again you're in this community so so
academia at least in the united states
was one of the first places where
computing was popularized
in particular email was of course
popularized in a couple of campuses in
the united states
they were sending research papers across
like arpanet or whatever those early
networks were
um and then along the way uh you had a
lot of these early tools so some of
these were unix emacs vi gcc
c library
perl linux and python came in 1991
relatively late
and so why i've highlighted these tools
in particular
if you squint your eyes you'll notice
that these tools are all open source
tools
but so what's really interesting is that
you see this really interesting
confluence in this these early days of
computing which is
the in the early days of at least
software collaboration mostly in the
united states you had folks
um in academia and then um
in these meetup groups a lot of them
they were meeting up so some somewhere
like this but obviously they didn't have
zoom back then
but they were creating the
they were using the software and they
were also using the software to create
the software so what do i mean by that
well they were getting together and then
they were going on forums
really primitive forms they were going
inside emails um
they were um and what were they doing
they were trading ideas they were doing
a lot of academic research like the
physics community computer sciences
community so they were doing very
fundamental research uh in networking um
and it's sort of obvious like if you
think about early adopters so these were
early adopters of these technologies so
they were interested in changing the
technologies themselves
so in addition to doing some of those
early you know hard sciences they were
actually
building the computer science protocols
themselves so they were you know
inventing tcp ip they were
building computers they were doing the
hardware the software the networking the
protocols they were saying like do we do
udp or do we do tcp what's the better
one so do we do packet switching versus
circuit switching what makes more sense
so to us you know modern
modern people in 2021 it's obvious like
oh of course it's tcp ip right of course
we used udp under these conditions and
dosing it back then it wasn't clear
people were doing research they they
were uh they were doing use research in
the
in the universities they were doing
research in industry partnering with you
know places like bell labs and so on and
so forth what's really interesting i
wanted to hone in on a specific
community was the open source community
so those tools are listed unix perl
python a c
c gcc the compiler for c unix linux all
those were open source software projects
and
so
i'm sure many of you are participating
in open source projects because like
even if you're not like one of those
weekend open source you know programming
nerds and i use that term in a very uh
nice way in a good way
you are nonetheless using open source
software in your daily activity because
your
your your stack at work is using some
open source software so open source is
not the future of the world it is what
you're using right now
um and if you're in pi data you're using
python that is open source right and so
when you think of open source what do
you think about well you think of github
well let me tell you like github is the
new kid on the block github is so super
super new
open source as i showed you earlier was
already around in the 50s and 60s that's
how people just collaborated didn't have
the notion of open source because
that's how universities and academia has
always worked
there's like almost no profit motive oh
it's only nowadays like github in the
past year or two that you can now
sponsor like open source maintainers
which is a great thing right don't get
me wrong but that was never the case
right so open source has always been a
thing and so how did people do open
source and how did people um collaborate
and as i mentioned earlier what they
could get together on forums they would
trade emails and they would meet up
but one key thing that they did is that
they would
get together and write code
asynchronously
and that's what you do today right so
you might have a code review right if
you're a data scientist
depending on your persuasion and this
might be controversial if you're a data
scientist like there's no like workflow
for data scientists this is like a wide
open thing whereas like in software
engineering you have like agile and then
you have like github and git lab and and
things like that and like devops and
then machine learning data science data
science workflows this is brand new so
there's many uh software startups in
this space trying to do all these tools
and this is very exciting um and so
um and you don't have that yet
but in any case nonetheless even though
you don't have that rigid flow i'm sure
you're still doing a lot of work
asynchronously i'm sure you're still
putting up you know prs in github or
merge requests in gitlab if you use that
at work and a lot of this is
asynchronous work you might get together
over a zoom call to do a
a code review but what you're probably
doing is you're writing some code you're
sending a pull request and somebody
reads it and gives you comments and then
you merge it into the mainline branch
the master branch
and it turns out that's always how
people have done it which is pretty
amazing like nobody thought of doing it
any other way um or maybe they did right
and they've quickly figured out that it
didn't work because
as a lot of you are you're an engineer
watching this and you know that
computers are dumb
if you miss a semicolon then your code
will break so it has to be
really crystal clear perfect
if you collaborate on a google doc and
you miss a period or you miss that
oxford comma somebody is going to yell
at you but the google doc will still
work it will still serve its purpose
your code will grind to a halt if it
doesn't work if you miss that semicolon
and even today it will not work there's
a lot of ways around it you know there's
like all these ways to mitigate that but
at the end of the day computers are dumb
so so these early pioneers of open
source collaborators they've always done
it this way
and in particular in the early early
days they didn't even have git so so
there's git there's github before github
there's git
um and so some of you might not know
that there are actually two different
things so before git there was things
like
cvs or svn so these were early version
control systems
so
if you use an early version control
system like
back in the day before git was
popularized you might have
been you know
you might have been cursed with using
sharepoint and what you had to do if you
write a program is that you would have
to check out a file and that file was
locked
and then you would write your code in
that file and you made sure your program
would run and then you would now upload
your file back into sharepoint microsoft
sharepoint and then you would unlock it
or close the lock
or release the lock that's the term and
so other people could check out that
file
and so later on
um
other source control systems would allow
you to um optimistically
check out the file even though it was
being checked out by other people but
then you have to resolve conflicts and
it was really horrible so later on uh
git was invented so so linus torvalds
was inventing linux so if you look at
the history um he started linux in 1991
as something uh as an improvement over
unix
and linus torvalds got really annoyed at
this collaboration i talked about you
know with this you know sharepoint and
other and other source control systems
and he said like this is too ridiculous
this is too complicated and so he
invented git and he released that in
2005 so that's that's really new if you
think about it 2005 so git was invented
in 2005. again there's no such thing as
github or git lab or or bitbucket none
of those things existed yet so git was
the first thing that came around
that that linus torvald shipped as a way
to help him and his community continue
to iterate on linux and so how they use
that was that they were able to
asynchronously work together to create
continue to create linux using git and
um and i'm sure a lot of you know how
git works or why git is special is
because you get the entire repository
and all changes of the repository
locally on your machine and so you can
jump on an airplane and continue to code
without the internet even though modern
planes do have the internet um so that
that's what really set things apart
with git
and so people were again were already
doing asynchronous collaboration over
git and they didn't have github they
definitely didn't have gitlab they
didn't have bitbucket but what they
would do is that they would send these
things called git patches so inside the
git protocol so so if you don't know
about this
git and github are totally different
things
git is a
terminal
um it's a terminal program
right on your you know your linux
terminal your unix terminal your windows
terminal it has it technically does not
have a web or a gui a graphical uni
interface it is all terminal based ui
and you can even have diffs right in git
right on your terminal you can you know
type the diff command you can compare
changes you can have the colors in terms
because modern terminals have colors and
that's how people would collaborate
before github
or even like sourceforge right they
would send git patches to each other
they would review the diff and they
would merge in the main line and they
would do this all over email
and then there's actually in the you can
do a man get uh and then you can look at
one of the commands which is like the
get patch command i believe it's called
and so along the way um people you know
some enterprising folks realize that why
don't we just build a web ui on top of
this because you know the internet was
starting to becoming a thing the web was
starting to become a thing really
quickly and um so you had repositories
which were the first version of like
open source innovation so you have these
things called like source forge uh you
know some of you might have used in
like many years ago but sourceforge was
a way to
store code and actually store binary so
it wasn't very developer centric
later on you had projects like google
code and then github and so they arrived
pretty much at the same time i believe
and but github was was the one that
really
shined because it was hyper focused on
the developer and they invented the pull
request which is really just a diff
right if you think about what's what's
the pull request well it is the get diff
on the terminal and they slap a web ui
on it and then they make it
collaborative in that there's a comment
thread
so the analogy here is that what did
google do to microsoft word well what
did google do well they made they just
took microsoft word and they made they
allow people to comment on it in a web
ui and so that's exactly what github did
and so these are these technologies
actually emerged at a similar time and
so that's what's really critical is that
these are a synchronous ways of
collaborating and so these early folks
had a way to collaborate asynchronously
again and so they didn't have to go into
a meeting all they did was they um you
know they just wrote some code they
wrote some comments and that that's
that's how github works and so on and so
forth
so
um i'm going to fast track to
how now so that that was the first part
sort of sort of just a quick overview of
the history
of what i would call async collaboration
and then i'll tell you now where does
this apply today and going forward
because everything i've explained might
be all good and well but like how does
that apply to you today well
what what what i personally experienced
was back in 2016 i i was an early
product manager at a company called
gitlab which is an open source
alternative to github and nowadays it's
pretty big so a good portion of you
watching this video probably know about
git lab you might use it as a weekend
project because you can install it on
your own machine but more likely you're
probably just working using it at in the
office
because a big proportion of uh you know
these fortune 500 companies and if you
work at a fortune 500 company you're
probably using gitlab because the
install base of of gitlab is mostly in
the enterprise
and so i was i was a early employee at
gitlab and gitlab was always remote
from day one and it was started in
europe as an open source project before
it became a company and so it had this
culture of doing everything that i just
mentioned very engineer
focused for in terms of the early
employees obviously a product
led a startup and also for those initial
customers were the developers themselves
so it made sense that the early company
was doing all this asynchronous
workflows so what was interesting is
that when i joined we were still very
early days as a product person and i was
starting to bridge
to a connection
between the technical staff and the the
growing business staff so if you've ever
done a startup or been in a startup
you know 90 of the staff is doing the
product uh or if you're doing at least a
product led startup a software startup
hardware store for that matter
90 of the staff are just engineers
working on the product as your product
grows in if especially if you're doing
an enterprise product your business your
sales staff your business development
staff is going to grow in proportion a
lot higher um
and especially if you get to like you
know obviously like a facebook sale or
google scale most a big proportion of
your staff is doing non-technical work
so the question we had as i joined the
company we had this inflection point
does it make sense that we continue to
do this type of asynchronous work
throughout the company can
the legal team can the biz dev team can
the marketing team can the product team
can the design team um
can
can all these teams aside from software
engineering even the operations team can
they
uh the customer success team can they
also work asynchronously and the answer
turned out to be yes and what's
interesting
is that we almost stumbled across this i
mean
some of it was luck and some of them was
we we thought really hard about it and
it turns out
one forcing function was remote work and
so this is how it ties into this past
year
when you have remote work when remote
work is forced upon you
uh in a blink of an eye which is
literally what happened in march of last
year
your entire company scrambles you don't
know what to do and in fact a lot of
these big companies were actually going
to gitlab and saying like what do we do
we don't know how to do this we've never
done this before
so that's terrible as a forcing function
because you have to react to it and so
you you see people scrambling people are
going crazy but if you're if you're a
small startup like gitlab and and you're
you've always been remote because you've
been a a
remote startup from day one and you're
starting to grow this company and you're
saying like do we continue to do remote
and so what the story goes is that um
the team they they hired a small team a
sales team in san francisco they had an
office and within a week
the sales staff just didn't come to the
office and so like the ceo says okay we
don't need this office so they just
closed down the office
so
what happened was that we didn't need
the office and people were just
experimenting
and remote became a forcing function and
a forcing function whether in technology
or social science or psychology
results in two things a forcing function
it results in like you're just oppressed
and you go and result in a really
negative situation which is what a lot
of companies end up in the pandemic or
you thrive you you innovate you figure
out some really awesome new things
and get lab had the benefit of being
really small not being forced into
remote there's no pandemic right in in
the early you know in the mid mid 2010s
uh when gillab was was growing right
they were forced to do remote work it
was a choice
and so this so sort of this this
fortuitous this virtuous cycle allowed
us to quickly innovate and we said that
this remote thing is amazing and so what
we said is like oh we chose remote it's
a forcing function but what can we do
to do to to take advantage of this it's
a forcing function but what can we we
take advantage let's not think of this
as a cost to be mitigated let's not
think of this as a business risk to be
mitigated but actually a strategic
advantage
for our business so what happens in
gitlab even today
is
meetings are a last result resort it's
not the first thing that people do
meetings are something you do
um if you can't do things async so so
the the model that gitlab did is really
interesting because it's essentially
the github pull request model it is a
source of truth which is the diff and
then there's a comment thread underneath
and you're commenting on the diff so
everything that happens in gitlab or
should happen in gitlab is that you have
a change request so
you know a change request is most of the
time not code if you're not an engineer
right so a change request is like uh
okay i'm doing a marketing launch next
week so i want to
write this blog post so my change
request is i want to do a blog post so
we have to discuss so i want to do a
blog post it's going to be at this time
it's going to be at this topic so i put
that out there
i at mention people and they they come
in and respond and as they respond in
the comment thread we update the source
of truth similar to a github pull
request you're updating that diff as
people make comments so so somebody says
like oh you this is a bad variable you
need to refactor this and they update
the diff and then finally they merge
that code in and so in the case of
gitlab is what we call we would use
issues gitlab issues sort of like github
issues to mediate this work there would
be this source of truth in the
description and then you have an
asynchronous comment thread and most of
the work
at gitlab gets done this way so this is
the power of asynchronicity this is
actually what a lot of companies have
started doing during the pandemic um
last year and so this is something
that's really powerful and the reason is
that um i'll go through some of the sort
of these principles from from
or from a first principles perspective
in a second i wanted to recall the
history this is essentially how people
have been doing um
asynchronous work and how that ties into
remote work uh and why why if you sort
of like
peek your nose and or google some of
this or like look in social media and
and think about like what are some of
the newer companies in past years have
been doing this they've been in like
google what is async work um and how it
relates to remote it is a way to avoid
these endless meetings whether they're
in person or on zoom so again
zoom is just a manifestation
of something a problem that's always has
existed
so that's why
if you google async remote
work or work from home you'll see all
these results and so some of these
bigger companies that you've heard of
recently in terms of shipping tools is
loom this is this async or video
platform so you can sync you can sync
async videos so you know in the consumer
space that's obvious that's what is that
like
instagram videos tick tock right you've
always had that forever and so
classical consumerization of it play
right so all these consumer technologies
and uis are now being applied to the
enterprise so you have loom which is
this video async video platform so
instead of sending slack messages you
send async video
instead of sending async video loom
which was just i think they got their
like series b or series c there's
another company called yak y ac and they
they're they're
they started in 2019 where looms started
in 2016. they're a little bit behind
them
and they allow you to send also
asynchronous video but they their bread
and butter is asynchronous audio so so
at gitlab and what all these companies
have done they've always been doing
asynchronous text
uh with a source of truth and so that's
been sort of like the traditional way to
do things and now people are
experimenting with asynchronous
video and then now asynchronous audio
and you see this this this trend and
this this change
um and then there's also this other set
of tools which i very disagree with
which is that vr thing i mentioned
earlier where they want you to be at
work all the time they want you to be on
zoom all the time and i really think
that that's not the future of work
because i've seen that firsthand and
that does not work but there are a lot
of startups taking that that that view
of the future work and i just don't
think that that makes sense
um
and and i wanted to mention
uh what was i gonna say yeah so so
there's there's there's uh oh yeah i
remember i was gonna say so gitlab we're
one of the early folks and gitlab is the
biggest company right now that is 100
remote obviously you know the googles
and facebooks as their folks
settle into this hybrid work from home
remote world obviously they're going to
have more staff that are remote but
think about a company that is 100 remote
versus hybrid it's super different and
we definitely don't have time today to
go through that
but
but the only company that is 100 remote
not the only company the the company
that has the most staff is gitlab so so
so we were inventing some really unique
things there
but i do want to give credit where it's
due which is
earlier companies was wordpress
so not wordpress automatic the company
that ships wordpress was super super
early
but they're not at the scale of gitlab
and they're all remote
envision a design company or ships
design tools and buffer and there's a
long tail of other companies that are
doing this again these are all smaller
companies and of course in chicago base
camp or formerly 37 signals
they're probably popular unpopular for
other reasons recently
but suffice it to say they were doing
remote work
very early on as well
so that's that's a local shop that's
been doing remote work so if you look at
any of the materials that these
companies put out that talk about remote
work they all say the same thing
asynchronicity
and being in and so if
the folks at basecamp they they've
published a couple of books
uh in the past and one of their books
they say that in that company they don't
even i've never worked there so i don't
know um but they don't have meetings or
if you want to have a meeting with
somebody um you have to like
beg somebody to have a meeting so it's
like a meeting is a really sacred thing
because your time is really valuable if
you think about it that really doesn't
make sense that
our modern meeting day tools is that you
literally just click a button and you
take an hour away from somebody's life
just like that if you think from like a
productivity dollars and cents
perspective that is so costly who are
you as what as a product manager to say
i
can take
you know
you work at google like these engineers
are paying like 300k
a year think about like the ridiculous
amount of money that one hour of their
life costs and who are you as a party
manager to take that from them so
whether it's from like the bottom line
of the company or just the sanity of the
engineer perspective that one hour is
super valuable and so it does not make
sense in our modern workplace that we
can just take people's time like that
and so so that's why
some of these companies have been doing
async
and that's what my company is doing so
if you're interested in learning more of
this and one of the strategies we're
doing you can always talk to me after
the fact and look at my my my contact
details but i want to spend the
remaining uh five minutes here really
quickly to talk about what are those
principles of asynchronous work i've
given you this history of giving you a
model of asynchronous work but i wanted
to step back and give you again a little
bit more principles
and benefits to really round it out some
of these takeaways because it and to
give you some maybe more tangibles um
and so one of them
is we talk a lot about synchronicity
another one is speed a lot of people
think async is doesn't that mean that
slow is
they say like this is this common common
um
uh
they say that async is slow i have to
type you this email and then you respond
and then it takes a day to respond that
slow that is actually wrong because if
you have a meeting or if you tap
somebody on the shoulder and most
meetings people are ill-prepared by the
way but if you tap somebody to show it
in the office or you slack them so by
the way slack is not async stack is
totally sync because slack mimics async
mimics the office synchronous place
because a slack message is literally
just tapping on the shoulder and how
many times have you been guilty you
watching this video of just spending an
hour on slack and scrolling through
mindless emoji reactions and you're not
actually doing work
so slack is synchronous and so
when you're doing synchronous work
it's actually a lot slower because
you're always in reactive mode somebody
says what do you think about this and
you're forced to respond in the moment
if you're doing asynchronous mode
somebody says what do you think about
this you actually take the time to
respond in a coherent manner you
actually think about it you you you do
the research and you respond and so how
asynchronous driven workflows and
companies work is that they have
multiple parallel streams of work so
when i was i working at gitlab i was
literally having 20 parallel
conversations easy with my engineering
manager counterpart per day he was five
hours ahead of me
in europe i was uh in east coast united
states and and we were going fast and
furious we were having like equivalent
of 20 meetings per day but not meetings
because it was asynchronous
conversations and if you want to talk
about speed and productivity
asynchronicity is speed and productivity
along with speed is small iterations
this is the classic
software engineering agile approach make
small iterations shift value to your
customer iterate so a lot of this is
tied into software so a lot of these
principles apply to like hardware and
doing different types of work but at the
end of the day if you think about it
knowledge work is about quick iterations
right knowledge work if you want to be
successful in today's modern business
era right you're gonna ship that you
know well you know super bowl commercial
is the batik is the counter example
because you do that once
once a year right but you do that
twitter campaign you see your
conversions and then your social media
person tweaks the campaign
and then changes something and then now
there's more conversions and that
happens literally within days or hours
so that's all about speed so if you want
to talk about speed that's speed and
what does that mean that means small
iterations so if you want small
iterations in your knowledge work or
your software whatever that means
that's a plus for async work because you
don't need to spend hours and hours of
meetings figuring out how to launch this
marketing thing or ship that product you
say i want to ship this here to the
feature i want to add this one button or
change this one color or add this one
tweet
if i'm a marketing person
and i can do that async because it's so
simple
so what happens is a lot of these
asynchronous companies every six weeks
or before the pandemic they would fly
them they would take all the budgets
saved from not having an office by the
way if you're a remote company they
would spend that budget and fly people
to a hotel every six weeks and maybe
four three four days up to a week they
would brainstorm do the high level
planning
and then they would go back home fly
back home for the next six weeks they
would iterate like crazy and then come
back uh
after the six weeks so it could be six
weeks it could be two months whatever
right it doesn't really matter at the
time but the focus is or what really
matters is if you think about it most of
your day as knowledge worker you're
really just doing small transactional
iterative things you're not doing this
huge brainstorming things day to day so
if that's the case small iterations wins
the day
and if you think about
what that means i'll give you two
examples uh manifestations of small
iterations
i've been told that at facebook if
you're an engineer on the first day
after you join the company you make a
commit
to master and and probably ship to
to production so they've set up their
their ecosystem their devops their their
engineering so that you cannot break it
and because they want people shipping in
small iterations
at amazon there's this thing called
two-way door decisions don't make
decisions where you can't go back on
it's a one-way door decision means that
you go one way you cannot go back so
they rather you mix
really
approach your business or structure your
business so you're making all these
two-way door decisions so you can always
quickly go backwards so it doesn't
matter if you're making small iterative
decisions you can always go back so so
minimize the risk mitigate the risk you
can move really quickly if you must make
a one-way decision you know avoid it
but you know prefer two-eight door
decisions
and
so you have speed you have a
synchronicity you have single source of
truth which i mentioned earlier which is
that that that you know that description
field and the issue that diff uh that
google doc that notion doc where you're
all collaborating together single social
truth is super important because if
you're working in the office or you're
working office before
you're practicing some of these
principles i've talked about you're just
doing broken telephone which is terrible
or you're go there there's this person
you go to this manager and they're in
charge of the information
if you're doing async work if you're
doing remote work if you're doing
different time zone work that kills your
productivity because that person goes on
vacation they're sick they're not in the
right time zone your business grinds to
a halt and so you do not want your
business based on people people should
you should be able to fire them and this
is actually why big companies force
identifications they want they don't
want people to to have this risk they
want the business to be able to run so
that's a forcing function that big
companies force you to to have vacation
single source of truth speed
asynchronicity
transparency helps all of that
transparency again helps with all that
so you can move faster you don't have to
have different you can have different
time zones transparency leads to
psychological safety as well so that you
can just come up with crazy ideas and
you can move really quickly so all of
these are wrapped up together and lastly
the most important thing if you're doing
all this asynchronous work you need a
culture of writing and i mentioned above
some of the tools that are on the market
now like with video and audio
um
and they're doing their best because you
know if you have video audio then but
like you want still want people watching
your video but it doesn't really make
sense so they're you know they're
transcribing the the video and the audio
into text text is always going to be the
number one uh thing in business your
reading is always going to be faster to
parse you can always search text you can
index text you can have ai you can have
all the ai in the world but text is
never going to go away in a business
setting
so that's why
great companies and great cultures
business workplace cultures async
cultures
people are great writers um and so
um
in the world of technology and code i
mentioned at the beginning of this talk
you cannot screw up because computers
are dumb
in
in the world of the rest of the company
and frankly even in engineering because
most a lot of your day is not just
writing code you have to communicate
like whatever you're doing with the rest
of the company and a lot of that is
business right
you there's so much room for error
because
people could say something they don't
mean something so and so forth so being
really good and being transactional
having a really crisp culture and being
very specific transactional that will
win you the day um in enterprise culture
so that's all i wanted to share today
hopefully you found this video
interesting um and
yeah i'll turn it back over to rebecca
great thanks so much victor um that was
a really great whirlwind history um i
learned a lot
um
yeah i didn't know that python appeared
on the scene so late
um
yeah so thank you everyone um mostly
people watching on youtube um we have
our meetups uh once a month usually the
last thursday of the month um i think
our next
month's meetup is probably already
posted on meetup.com so stay tuned and
thank you